Good morning, Hank. It's Thursday, August 3, 2017.
It's Esther Day!
So 7 years ago today,
our friend Esther Earl made a video where she said in part,
"...and I love my sisters, I love my brother,
I love my dad, I love my mom, and I love my pets. They are included
in the family category.
I love my friends. My friends are amazing.
The ones I've met online. The ones that I still have IRL."
Esther died a few weeks later when she was just 16.
And every year we pause on August 3,
her birthday, to celebrate Esther Day,
a celebration of love in all its many splendors.
And Esther wanted us to pay special attention to the kinds of non-romantic love
that often go unacknowledged in our culture,
love among family and friends.
So Hank, with that noted, I love you.
I so admire your hard work, your relentless pursuit
of decreasing world suck, your love and kindness
and patience as a son and father
and husband and brother.
I think you're amazing, and I love you. And I will not say that again for a year.
In honor of Esther Day, I hope all of you out there will take a moment
to tell people in your lives that you love them,
even if it's hard to do, in fact, especially if it's hard to do.
After Esther died, her family created This Star Won't Go Out,
a charity that has helped many, many families of kids with cancer.
But this Esther Day, This Star Won't Go Out
is expanding its mission in a way Esther would have loved
with something called Project Lovely.
That logo, by the way, was made by Emily Cole, using
a font made from Esther's actual handwriting.
So you can find out much more about this at ProjectLovely.org,
but basically people between the ages of 13 and 30 can
apply for a $5000 grant,
to do something to make the world better.
It can be anything that will make the world better.
You can apply at ProjectLovely.org.
Two people will be chosen and given $5000,
and then we'll follow their projects.
Esther loved the Project for Awesome and Harry Potter Alliance initiatives,
and I think this is a really beautiful way for her family and friends
to continue her legacy.
And if you want to donate to This Star Won't Go Out, you can do so at TSWGO.org.
I also highly recommend Esther's memoir, "This Star Won't Go Out."
It's a beautiful book available wherever books are sold.
Thanks to Esther and her amazing family for continuing to inspire our community.
Happy Esther Day everybody!
Hank, I look forward to saying, "I love you," again
in just 365 short days.
I will see you tomorrow.